[Musique]
n'achetez pas les reposes 2 qui se
recharge sans fil
pourquoi comme en finale je vais pas
vous dire ne pas acheter les repos de
deux parce que je les trouve juste top
j'ai trouve vraiment vraiment bien et
apple a fait un excellent boulot avec
ses airs podz salle a ses petits trucs
là c'est un accessoire de ouf
alors je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je
vous fais ce titre de vidéos n'achetez
pas à l'ère post 2 qui se recharge sans
fil on voit là je ne sais pas comment je
vais l'écrire exactement bon je fais la
vidéo mais n'achetez pas cette config
pourquoi parce que j'aime la rpdh et
parce que l'airpod font plusieurs
promesses quand vous allez sur le site
d'apple vous avez une promesse qui est
fait par les apps sharepoint plus
magique que jamais temps de conversation
augmenté activation vocale de syrie et
nouveau boîtier de charge sans fil les
nouveaux vols sont des écouteurs sans
fil et sans commune mesure
retirez les lans mortiers et il
fonctionne tout de suite avec tous vos
appareils portés les à vos oreilles il
se connecte immédiatement ou va profiter
d'un son de haute qualité parfaitement
détaillés plus que géniaux ils sont
magiques plus que géniaux ils sont
magiques
ça c'est une promesse alors c'est une
très très belle phrase marketing mais
c'est une vraie belle promesse l'airpod
sont magiques
je suis d'accord avec quasiment tous les
points qui sont données par apple hier
potes sont alors belgique font pas
vraiment magique mais l'airpod sont
vraiment géniaux
si on reprend temps de conversation
augmenté pour vous les prenez vous les
placez à vos oreilles ça marche
directement ça se connaissent et
pratiquent c'est bien vous avez une plus
grosse autonomie ça c'est cool
vous avez 5 heures d'autonomie l écoute
de musique vous avez trois heures en
appels et vous avez 24 heures de musique
grâce au petit boîtier de recharge ça
c'est cool c'est pratique c'est
l'expérience de base activation vocale
deux séries ça c'est aussi un poids qui
est assez intéressant parce que avant
pour utiliser siri sur bois repose il
fallait appuyer dessus un peu partout
dans le sens de faciliter les technos
sont toujours plus facile plus
transparent vous les prenez vous dites
10 séries et vous dites ce que vous avez
à dire et nouveau boîtier de charge sans
fil
c'est ça qui m'intéresse parce que pour
moi nouveau boîtier de charge sans fil
aujourd'hui ça ne sert strictement à
rien bon alors on s'assoit tranquille on
prend le temps on réfléchit et on se
pose la question pourquoi est ce qu'au
final le fait d'avoir de la recharge
sans fil sur des airs pote sincère
strictement
rien dans l'absolu c'est l'idée géniale
j'aurais adoré que ça serve à quelque
chose
on va re situer le contexte qu est-ce qu
apple qu'elle est l'adn d'apple c'est
vous proposer le meilleur très facile à
utiliser
extrêmement transparent vous prenez vous
appuyez ça marche vous posez pas de
questions c'est simple les produits
fonctionnent ensemble sur un écosystème
fermé et fonctionne à merveille et
parfaitement bien donc l'expérience au
niveau des reposes est complètement
réussi mais le problème de ces repose 2
en recharge sans fil c'est qu'on n'est
pas dans le bon timing et la raison
s'appelle air power alors or si tu on
est sur la keynote de septembre 2017
apple nous présente son nouvel iphone 10
nouvel iphone 10 en recharge sans fil et
nous annonce l'arrivée du sans fil chez
apple
ça c'est génial c'est une belle
évolution parce que l'idée du sans fil
chez apple c'est une suite logique oncle
et d'avoir une grande malle de recharge
sur lequel vous posez indifféremment sur
une plaque de recharge vos différents
objets vautard pod votre smartphone
votre apple watch se recharge tout
simplement c'est une excellente idée
sauf que on arrive en 2019 air power
n'est pas là et repower a été enterré
purement et simplement par apple on sera
sûr apple nous a dit la recharge sans
fil
on y croit on va continuer à travailler
dessus et si on lit entre les lignes on
croit deviner qu'apple proposera de la
recharge sans fil comme il sait le faire
quelque chose de transparent de facile
d'évident pas se dire ah ben tiens ça
c'est la zone pour ça c'est la zone pour
ça non on devrait avoir un produit
intéressant mais aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas et c'est justement pour ça qu'on
a un problème aujourd'hui avec certes
pause parce que si vous vous avez suivi
un peu l'histoire
apple nous a proposé deux versions des
reposes 2 une version de base qui est
une mise à jour au même tarif que les
autres et repose 179 euros profité de la
dernière génération de rpoint toujours
une grosse qualité audio plus autonomie
10 séries en commande vocale vins
intéressants 179 euros
il se moque pas de vous il augmente pas
de prix et pour toutes les personnes qui
ne sont pas équipés des reposes ça vaut
le coup à côté de ça il nous présente
une deuxième version 2 129 euros avec de
la recharge sans fil et sa très
clairement pour moi il ne faut pas
lâcher aujourd'hui
tout simplement parce qu'il n'a pas
encore sa place dans l'écosystème
alors oui on pourrait se dire j'ai déjà
ma petite base de recharge sans fil je
le prends je le pose dessus ça n'a pas
de sens ça n'a pas de sens parce qu'on
n'est pas dans l'adn
apple l'adn d'apple font que ce soit
transparent aujourd'hui c'est pareil
vous avez des iphone 10 iphone 10
petites zones de recharge éventuellement
pour un smartphone
ça peut s'entendre mais dès lors vous
arrivez en plus avec des accessoires
comme ça parce qu'on est bien sûr un
accessoire vous allez pas vous dire
maintenant je vais prendre une deuxième
base de recharge sans fil ou alors
j'attends que mon iphone soit chargée
que sa charge pas très très vite pour
ceux téléchargés mais repose ça ne
marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas on est à
l'encontre même de l'adn d'apple on va
complexifier
on va avoir deux blocs de recharge ou
alors une espèce de gros blocs qui n'est
pas apple qui n'est pas certifié et qui
n'est pas je dirais dans ce que veut
faire est dans l'adn d'apple donc c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui pour moi c r paul
ii qui se recharge sans fil n'ont pas
leur place dans l'écosystème d'apple
c'est évident que ça fait un moment qu
apple travaille sur ces airs potts 2 il
s'était dit on va présenter les airs
paul ii on aura air power qui va arriver
en même temps et là il ya un vrai sens
et très clairement et d'ailleurs si vous
regardez au dos de la boîte des reposes
2 déc l'option de recharge son fils il
est écrit qu'il fonctionne avec air
power
mais comme il ya une grosse plantade sur
air power serpos de en recharge sans fil
pour moi n'ont aujourd'hui pas leur
place dans l'écosystème d'apple pour
continuer dans la logique du sans fil
apple a proposé juste la boîte vide sans
vos airs potes pour mettre vos airs
paul's 1 à l'intérieur 89 euros pour
aller dans le sans fil
ça peut avoir un sens dans la mesure où
l'écosystème apple est prêt mais
l'écosystème apple n'est pas prêt je
vous ai parlé il ya quelques jours de la
mort de air power et qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire derrière ça voulait dire
que apple a mis la charrue avant les
boeufs et avec les airs post 2 c'est
exactement la même chose
ils ont mis la charrue avant les boeufs
allant peut-être qu'il s'était dit que
sa lettre le bon timing tout à l'arrivée
au bon moment et très clairement pas
alors soit d'ici quelques mois une sorte
une nouvelle version de air power une
vraie bonne version qui marche peut-être
pas sous le nom et repower et à ce
moment-là ça pouvait avoir un sens sinon
serpos de recharge son fils n'ont
strictement aucun sens 229 euros pour un
produit qui au final ne trouve pas
complètement sa place dans l'écosystème
ça marche pas par contre et c'est
justement pour ça que moi j'ai acheté
l'airpod 200 la recharge sans fil parce
que je n'ai pas complètement sur mon cou
par rapport à air power et voyez
beaucoup j'ai bien fait je me suis pas
planter donc j'ai acheté des faits repos
2 2 qui fonctionne parfaitement bien
merveilleusement bien aussi bien avec
votre mac avec votre iphone que sur
android bien
il est complètement optimisé pour
fonctionner avec ios mais même sans
eyeos profiter d'une qualité audio qui
est vraiment top
alors il eu pas mal de choses ont été
dites sur ces airs pop the way mais les
reposes de ils vont passer moi ya pas de
réduction bruit active pour moi la
réduction de bruit active là dessus
c'est aller à l'encontre on aime de
l'adn de ces produits ces produits vous
les prenez vous les posez il faut pas
vous boucher les oreilles ils vont juste
venir se poser sur votre règle ils le
font parfaitement bien et du coup vous
captez encore du son extérieur installé
une réduction de bruit active là dessus
ça n'aurait strictement aucun sens et ça
irait à l'encontre même de l'adn de ce
produit j'ai même vu quelques personnes
qui étaient déçus parce que l'airpod
était uniquement en blanc c'est l'adn
d'apple
on reste vraiment dans l'adn d'apple
l'adn d'apple c'est ça c'est ça les
petits airs pote blanche
ce ne sont pas des apports noir ce ne
sont pas des reposes une zone rouge ce
que vous voulez on est chez apple on
reste dans un design très pur très
sophistiqué facile beau élégant et pro
coup ça marche donc je voulais pas qu'il
faut pas jeter à l'ère post 2 si vous
n'avez pas de l'airpod et si vous voulez
acheter dr paul vous pouvez y aller mais
n'achetez pas l'air pose avec la
recharge sans fil à 229 euros
et si vous avez des reposes 1 n'allez
pas acheter le boîtier à 89 euros pour
le recharger sans fil alors que
l'écosystème d'apple et même temps après
quelques pas de sens il ya franchement
pas de sens si vous voulez der pol si
vous voulez des baux écouteurs apple
sont faciles à connecter qui ont une
belle qualité audio qui sont bien vous
avez syrie à la commande vocale et vous
avez un peu plus d'autonomie pour
l'appel
l'airpod deux sont franchement très bien
mais si vous intéresse vous avez un lien
en bas dans la description
je voulais déjà dit je vous dis une fois
de plus apple ses marques que j'aime
beaucoup apple innove
il ya la recherche et développement
derrière il ya toujours beaux produits
qui sortent et ce qu'il fait tout l'adn
de cette marque est souvent critiquée
pour son prix mais ce qu'il faut
vraiment comprendre c'est tout beau
derrière qui en r&d il est énorme pour
ce soit simple transparent évident et
c'est tout ça l'adn de cette marque et
je trouve vraiment qu'ils sont plantés
avec cette histoire de air power et
qu'au final ça rend caduque
cr poste 2 en recharge sans fil je sais
pas si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
dites le moi en bas en commentaire est
ce que vous êtes d'accord que au final
ça vaut pas le coup d'acheter ces aires
pose en recharge sans fil est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que si on
veut acheter dr paul il faut les acheter
en recharge lightning à moins d'avoir 15
oc de recharge et d'avoir une maison au
final qui est moche je pose ou ce soir
je mets ou quoi comment sinon je vois
vraiment pas l'intérêt
je sais qu'il existe des espèces de
d'alternative à ce qu'on aurait pu être
et repower
mais on est loin de l'écosystème d'apple
et le côté simple intuitif et évident
donc on n'est pas dans l'adn en tout cas
de la marque dont je vois pas l'intérêt
d'aller acheter sa vie parce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec moi
oui non quoi comment on en débat je vous
invite à y regarder ma playlist
s'affiche par là où par là avec tous mes
tests d'objets connectés de castres ou
du dos et compagnie et je vous dis à
très bientôt vous embrasse à bientôt